the streets said that all the streets
are talking
you dated him and he was married to
her
so what actually happened was I'm on a
show
and they told me we're going to bring in
a new wife when I met her and her
husband I didn't really Place him at the
moment but I knew him already
fast forward it just didn't work out for
her and she left wait were they married
or dating they were married she was
allegedly cheating on him I will not
speak on her
it might help my girl out here
Holland allegedly cheated on Simon and
then got pregnant so I kind of feel like
yeah Simon was done with the marriage
because his wife got knocked up by the
pool boy allegedly
after that they actually announced that
they were getting a divorce I hit him in
the DMs like I'm praying for you I hope
you're good
so hit me back like yeah I'm good when
you come in Atlanta let's get together I
was like oh cool well he hit me I was
like I'm in Atlanta I want to see you
and I think before I see you I need you
to email me your divorce papers you were
being very thorough I had to be I'm a
public figure and I don't want to
represent that yep so she signed it it
was a done deal oh but it was not
finalized it was just literally sitting
on the judge's desk
now Porsha girl
girl I like you
to be good I want us to be friends but
this is quite the contradiction from
what the Saints in the street have been
saying but during that time he's free to
do what he wants to do absolutely and we
got engaged in literally under a month
we know
the hardest part about the whole
experience is just how public it was and
just how let down some of my fans were
was a little difficult because people
really didn't understand what was going
on but at the end of the day what stands
the test of time trip test if you move
with a good heart just stand on truth
truth will always Trump a rumor I'm all
about taking a man
if you could find a man that likes you
more than whoever he's with I mean I'll
take a man I'm not proud of it but I've
taken a man too I mean me looking at
Porsha's ring that's a good ring
I'd steal that man too because it's like
a woman's show so you know a lot of men
are actually like you know embarrassed I
mean I can speak like for my husband
that's a businessman and he's in I think
real estate and you know he's like he's
like I don't need the show so would you
walk away from the show if you felt like
it was like destroyed I've already had
this conversation with my husband I'm at
a point in my life that my personal life
is more important this is my third
marriage you know my kids are older like
you know I I'm just not so interested in
my brand was there like a gay husband
yeah my second husband when he passed
away I found out that he was in a
relationship with a man I was legally
still married to him and we had a great
relationship so we had to get together
his children from his previous marriage
this music's great this story is so good
I know it already
we're separated for a year we never
divorced legally it was bisexual because
he obviously married me and we were
together
[Music]
I feel like Alexia has like a loop you
know what I mean and she has her things
that she talks about she's sticking to
them and it's like a script
I was legally still married to him and
we had a great relationship it's like a
soulmate thing so I fell in love with me
for like who I was but then other
factors came into play why don't you
guys like order shots can you guys like
get drunk or something
[Music]
break it down